true story true story in the news that I
found very interesting check it out
NASA's super muscular mice return to
Earth from space we did not make that up
this is true apparently NASA did
experiments in space on mice and they
genetically engineered the mice to be
very very muscular yes well now they're
back on earth or safe and get this we
were able to get our hands on some
footage of these muscular mice yeah
we're the only ones that have this
footage I'm told it's pretty impressive
let's take a look look at that what's he
doing he's there's a mouse and I don't
know what he's doing I think he's oh yes
yes I see what he's doing now he's
making a protein shake yeah it was his
other mouse cow yeah there he is there's
a mouse bench-pressing another mouse
very impressive
this mouse I don't know what he's doing
he seems to be flexing and look he
shaved his chest and he's flexing in the
mirror yes oh no they shoved a cat into
a locker he's muscular mice yeah and
they're just being bullies now now
they're flushing the cat's head in a
toilet
churches that these aren't good mice and
finally they're giving that very same
cat Oh wedgie yeah while the other Mouse
uploads it onto Instagram which is just
bullying behavior
you